You nicknamed me, many years
ago you came on the show
and we were talking about nicknames
and I said, what would my nickname be
and you said, "Coner Boner".
(audience laughing)
I have a new one for you now.
Oh, you have a new one?
Okay, 'cause I thought that was fantastic.
I know.
What's the new one?
I think you need an upgrade.
Yes, thank you.
So, in light of this movie
and the Statesman,
Statesman wanna offer you
a new nickname.
I will take any nickname,
I've been Coco for a while
and it's done nothing for me.
Okay.
So I'm ready
to move on, yeah.
This one might help you a little bit,
it's Aperol ...
[Man In Audience] I love you.
(audience laughing)
Thank you.
Wow, he chose his moment perfectly.
(audience laughing)
It's about to be about you.
He was in line thinking,
"If I get in there."
When Halle Berry starts to talk,
I'm gonna wait until she starts saying
something real important
to tell her I love her.
And the Darth Vader helmet
goes right back on again.
(audience laughing)
I want to hear my nickname.
I'll take care of you,
don't worry, you're mine.
Grrr!
Agrrr!
Okay, so your new name is Aperol Spritz.
What, Aperol?
What's that?
Well, I brought a picture of it.
[Conan] I don't know
what an Aperol Spritz is.
That's an Aperol Spritz.
(laughing)
[Channing] Can I offer another option?
But wait, but wait, it's like that.
Your hair used to be much redder.
It used to be much redder,
yeah, I'm getting old.
That's why I came up with that.
Yeah, okay, Aperol Spritz.
Aperol Spritz ...
Yeah, you know what?
Dudes really fear when
Aperol Spritz comes to town.
(audience laughing)
Channing, you had another idea?
Just another option, Fireball.
[Man In Audience] We love you!
[Conan] What's that?
Fireball.
No, no, no.
And helmet back on.
I can't hear anything.